Zanna Roberts Rassi!
That's so sweet, thank you so much for having me.
This show is my 9:00 a.m. sunshine
every day.
Oh good.
Well we've been friends for a long time,
done many collabs, many endeavors,
we talked about doing this show for a long time
so here we are, finally, Zanna, let's start us off
on some news stories.
Oh my gosh, okay, let's kick us off with beauty news.
So Farrell's new skin care line,
it not only keeps your skin happy, had to drop that in,
but also helps the earth.
GQ reports that Human Race line,
aims to reduce plastic waster by using
refillable chambers made of recycled materials.
Now let's just talk about this packaging, shall we?
Because, Drew-
I have straight up,
componentry envy.
I do, I love Milk's packaging,
I care very much about Flower's packaging,
we're fanatics about picking the vessels, the components,
creating stock, you know, components creating custom.
This guy, he nails everything!
This is so beautiful, so vibrant, it's refillable,
it's 50% post-consumer plastic.
So, instead of going to a landfill,
it's back in a new product.
You know what I thought when I saw it too?
I was like, "God this is crisp!"
It's crisp!
It smells grassy green, you can almost feel it's fresh,
doesn't it?
_ I know!
And it's just beautiful, everything he does is incredible.
And even looking at his skin,
he's a walking ad for great skin care.
There's not a line, not a pore,
I once asked him on a carpet, I cornered him and said,
"So, what's the secret, what are we using here?"
And he actually told me that his tips
come from Naomi Campbell.
Really?
Yeah, so two tips we can actually all use at home.
One, splash cold water on your face once you've washed it,
closes the pores, gives it a fresh look.
Secondly, don't fight gravity,
always apply product it the upward motion.
I mean it's common sense, but actually
when you're doing it in a rush, it's kind of like,
oh, oh, oh.
I know
I wash my face, like Leatherface.
It's like a chainsaw, I'm just like, ahh!
(upbeat music)